I've asked the people to get out some
numbers for me so that remember at the
beginning I asked you to make a
prediction about whether you thought
like was the chance very high very low
as a percentage
what was your chance of winning and
escaping Baltimore rescuing everyone or
all your chances of getting killed
okay now don't actually say yeah but who
reckons they have the highest that is
the most optimistic percentage for the
number of reads who thinks they have a
very high number anyone okay Jordan
what's your number 84 percent anyone
gonna be a full 90% okay as a chance of
winning right once out of lobby right
it's like it's 50 percent every time 50
percent every time does that make sense
okay who records their video down I had
a very pessimistic you wreck today the
lowest number okay 10 down what did you
do 40% you want to go lower than 47%
here we go low at 7-7 sevens on the
horse memo okay I can understand this
thing here what you just did right in
some senses this might be one of those
important lessons that you learn today
namely this side ear off we said
probability and the name is my B's
probability but it's really about chance
and on 17 okay we live our lives every
day which Hanson on said to you it's not
as B as a die in fact it's more like
what this game is like where look at
look at the up the range of SS and I
assume everyone in between
okay and that's kind of what life is
like right like you you're not sure
what's gonna happen but you have to make
an action in nonetheless okay this side
here estimating the chance that
something will happen right
this is really
the important numerical skill right so
that wasn't just the old that wasn't
just a cheap shot right it was actually
something really valuable to do and he's
a thing right we have Donna now it's on
the board to actually work out a
percentage because based on yours for
instance if I was just now this is Kyle
this is you right you're Daniel okay now
if I just played this number games ten
games right what would you conclude is
your chance of winning you the Shoom
it's 50/50 if that's all you've seen
right I'm glad there's no one here
you're never one ever right but suppose
you played the game and it's like I
never won
I just lost ten times in a row it
wouldn't be that unreasonable to assume
that the chances what's it's impossible
or at least it's less than ten percent
something for very very low so I asked
some people to prepare some numbers for
me Daniel how many do you do it's you
add up weeds right how many wins in
total are there as a boy 26 26 wins okay
mister huge number of losses a hundred
and two losses okay
now pause for a second I'm interested in
a chance of probability right I asked
you about wins no losses even the kind
of the same thing right so wins the
probability of a win through this
experiment that you guys have just done
it which what to the daughter the
Fandral outcomes are 26 what goes on the
denominator it's going to be the total
sample space the number of times we play
games which is 120 now ask for
percentage right can someone give it to
me 25 points for
we just go cool ok 25.4% alright who
records they go closest to that number
great what did you get 20% anyone think
they got hot course of the 20 25 %
that's if you yeah that's right if you
didn't do decimal places that's the
question you get 25 percent is that
close this estimate now stop for a
second I want you to carefully
you're not looking for this number what
you do I
sulo and how did you arrive at that
number okay I'd like you to make it
heading which is complimentary events
okay now we're gonna start to get
towards this number but we're going to
introduce this idea which is really just
broadly useful okay you've met this word
before complementary you've ever we're
doing bench in Yorba tree right in
geometry if I have an angle like this
okay I'm a right angle in there and then
I've got some reader weakling over there
and pick right you'd go and then add B
when you add the book together you're
gonna get I like 90 degrees cuz the
right a go on this side there must be
writing on this side right so we say a
is B Elementary now that's just really a
general tab called the bit please spell
over to these by the way when you spell
it with an eye
that's like nice haircut okay come to me
a bit this is a combination is the same
Wesley it just means these two go
together things go together right so
these go together they make a right
angle
that's what complimentary beads in
geometry if your parents or do you like
foodies and they're kind of you did talk
about complimentary wines or why it goes
with a particular kind of food it just
means they go together in probability
right and hold the victory events are
again events that go together here so
I'm gonna do a straight up right
underneath you we played this game we
can work out pretty easily on a
individual role what's the probability
of getting killed by more than one right
we can we could know this right because
of the die there are six faces right and
Voldemort is one of those faces here's
the six right so we would say this
outcome is one out of six
what is six face something so they don't
say as you try to roll you're trying to
do your pursuit right you were trying to
do something else we try to rescue
someone right so I could say the
probability of rescuing
and this assuming you know when you when
you first roll and not worry about the
fact that if you'd rescued someone you
can't risk it again don't worry about
that it's simply the opposite of this
right so what I think it's five out of
six right now just before you write five
out of six before you write five abysses
I want you see that either this event or
this event one of these has to happen
every time you roll right by I mean like
I said you know you rest me how good
you've already rescued it but you're not
you're not dying right so one of these
must happen right
in other words speaking back to the
words we have over this side of the
board right one of these is set or
definite or sure you'll definitely have
one of these so therefore it stands to
reason that the probability of this was
probably of this if it's certain it
should add up to it should add up to 1
right because it's seven a hundred
percent chance right so I'm going to
write the probably of rescue someone
plus the probability of getting killed
on one that's equal to one these
definitely have to happen right one or
the other must happen for sure
they're opposite events right they go
together and that's why we call them
call the Met remix
hey complementary okay they cook them
through because one or the other must
happen
going back to flipping coins right heads
and tails are complementary events okay
now come back to the diagram right let's
take you save five and six rolling a 5
or rolling a 6 only have five Murali is
six are not complementary events right
they are different but they're not
complementary because you know I could
just roll and sure enough I go to three
right it wasn't a five or six right so
getting a five or six is not certain
it's just this is part of it right so
for instance a tree it's heads or tails
Voldemort or rescue someone they're the
things that go together
hence complementary question okay so
it's funny yes you're right I mean we
did to match those two as you go as far
as I know supper the tree doesn't really
have a beating in probability I think
they kind of they use this one up and
they're like yeah but just a nice good
okay now I'm gonna fish this off now
right cuz you already know what the
probability I'm gonna kill my Baltimore
it is right so I'm gonna write this like
sir just going down to the next line and
probably arrest you someone plus this
probability which is just a seat that's
really one right one of these definitely
has to happen that's why it's a one
synapse rearranging that probability of
rescue someone if I take that one seeks
over to the other side that's what gives
me the five six that you already
expecting before okay now another
question for you right um Krieger target
mission if the probably rescue so it's
five out of six that's quite high if you
crunch the come on if your calculator
that's like 80 something
84% okay so why is it if this is 84% why
is it the probability of actually
reading the game is not 84% Daniel what
he did yes very good
that's right so you see right the reason
why this 84% running up and down I think
it's rounding down 83 84 okay this is
just too risky one person but this
you've gotta rescue all five right so
this is like it's a bit like saying can
you flip heads over and over and over
again it's not hard it's going to be
half that it's giving you a quarter that
it's an eighth and then how everybody
has you want to flip then it's gonna be
less and less probable okay he comes
down to another like this okay so what
were a little bit of notation because
this idea of complementary events right
it's very very important let me
abbreviate a little bit let's just call
one more thing I think so the
probability of E is 1 over 6 okay
because it becomes useful to talk about
things happening or not happening we
introduced this little simple yeah which
is a little squiggly line above whatever
event you're describing thank you it's
like a tilt it is the same kind of
symbol used for estimate but here what
it means is compliment okay so it's like
what's the probably a volleyball killing
you
well it's the problem probability of him
not kill me okay so this is like saying
the bills whatever that is the opposite
of whatever that is the compliment so
this is on the side of this one take
away a six it's five six
okay
now just be careful just before we set
off on the exercise we'll have about ten
minutes
note that this is the crucial idea here
whatever events you want to think about
if they're called the tree they have to
add up to one okay so for example there
are some of its that you might think are
opposites
for example whoops the probability other
being sunny or the probability of it
raining okay now these look like they're
complementary but they aren't are they
okay because you know it could be
neither sunny nor rain it could be like
overcast right so these two don't add up
to 1 they aren't definitely going to
happen and either of them might happen
ok so you have to be very careful what's
actually complementary together